what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and i'm in la right now
i'm at my l.a place because last night
was the launch event for she-hulk
attorney at law and i gotta say
going into this show i i didn't have any
idea what to expect i really didn't i
i didn't know what my expectations were
because the trailers came out i'm like
this could be a lot of fun
this could be dumb this could be amazing
um and today is kind of just my initial
reactions to watching the first four
episodes i watched the first four
episodes last night at the launch event
um before that i had only seen one
because disney sends out the screeners
but i decided to only watch one because
i wanted to make this video i wanted it
to be fresh and of course genuine
so this is my initial reaction to the
first four episodes and the show overall
so far i do have a little bit of notes
that i kind of made but i wanted to be
pretty candid just you know speaking to
you all bluntly and honestly and uh it's
a it's not a review
this is just my reaction so no spoiler
is going to be in this video tomorrow is
when the actual review embargo lifts i
will do a spoiler free review and then
of course tomorrow night we will be
doing our watch parties for she-hulk now
right off the bat like i said
i i didn't know
how i was going to feel about the
episode
uh about the series as a whole that is
um after i watched the first episode i
initially thought oh hey
i enjoyed that um
i did i actually really enjoyed the
first episode i think it might be
my favorite one
um
this isn't really a spoiler it's an
origin story right and yeah they change
the origin i think we all knew that was
going to happen but it doesn't deviate
too much from the original comic origin
to where i think people will
be mad about it plus it's the mcu you
know they always kind of just change
things we can't have it exactly like
it's going to be from the comics
otherwise we would know everything
that's going to happen now sometimes
they keep the origins true and sometimes
they change them and that just is what
it is i think fans are going to be okay
with the origin of this
how it all happens it's not that
different well at the same time being
different and being a little bit fresh
now
tatiana maslany she actually crushes it
um
going into this i liked her already
and i thought she was gonna do a good
job and she did and i'm really happy
about that i'm really glad um because i
really wanted her to do a good job and
she did i think she is she hulk i think
she's going to be around in the mcu for
a very long time so i hope everybody
else likes her as well um i don't think
this show is for everybody
i think it can be enjoyable for
everybody but i don't think it's going
to be everyone's favorite show i saw a
lot of tweets yesterday just going
through all the reviews everybody on
twitter all the posts on instagram and
stuff of people saying it's their
favorite their new favorite show uh not
for me and i don't mean that it's like
oh it sucks i just mean that like loki
and one division are still at the very
top for me
and this doesn't cross over that for me
it it doesn't it's so fun and enjoyable
and
i was pleased by it and i had a fun time
watching it and i i laughed i laughed a
lot uh some jokes don't hit
uh and some do and some deeper moments
hit and some deeper moments don't hit um
again not going into any detail but
you'll figure out figure it out soon
now one thing i will say is that each
episode has a post credit
but but calm down because it's not like
the post credits set up like a a bunch
of huge stuff it's really like gags
and i actually enjoyed them i think the
first one had me laughing like really
really hard like
i was like that was a good joke so like
i said i had a really fun time with the
show and i've only seen the first four
episodes i can't i can't predict how
it's going to end but
so far i'm here for the ride i hope it
ends strong because i think it has the
potential to be a very good
show now i think this is kind of gonna
be like thor love and thunder i really
loved thor love and thunder but like
half of the fandom didn't half of them
thought it was like a little too much
and i think
it's gonna be the same thing for she
hulk i think that half of the fandom is
going to really love it i think this
show is going to get a very specific
really hardcore following
by a lot of people i do i really do and
then i think some people are gonna hate
it unfortunately um
i think marvel is kind of in the face
right now they are catering towards
specific people like ms marvel was kind
of catered towards like a younger
generation right um but then it had the
things that connected into the overall
bigger picture of the mcu and this is
pretty much how she hulk is now i will
say one thing i really really liked
about this series is that each episode
sort of stands on its own
there is an
overall
story that kind of connects and
everything like that but
each episode is kind of its own thing
i've heard the set up there and it's
really great example of like what this
show is uh instead of marvel trying to
make like
a six hour movie with a disney plush
show they simply made they aimed to make
each episode good
and like its own thing which i really
enjoyed
i
i don't know the formula that marvel
studios is trying for disney plus but i
think maybe trying to make you know nine
episodes because there are nine episodes
of she-hulk and instead of trying to
make
you know
a four and a half hour movie
six hour movie whatever it may be
uh just aim to make each episode good
and i think that's what they did this
show has so many great characters in it
and i'm not even talking about like
cameos i'm talking about just like the
normal characters in it i think a lot of
the times like my reaction would be like
i like him i like her like i really like
this character i really you know hope
this turns into something i hope he
shows up more i hope she shows up more
um
i i'm really really liking titania i
want to see a lot more of her i think
she is going to be really really cool
character and uh
there's no spoilers here because i
haven't seen anything yet but like the
connection to doom i really want to know
titania's origin story because in the
comics she becomes who she is because of
doom so there's a lot of potential with
this series and i'm genuinely excited to
see where it goes um i will address one
other thing
maybe a couple other things but the cgi
um
we complained about the cgi in the
trailer and i think people are still
going to complain about the cgi
in the episodes i think after i was done
watching it i was sitting there going
like
it wasn't horrible but sometimes you're
like
this is off and you can't really tell
what it is
you can just kind of tell it's off
some people might notice that some
people might not notice it um but
overall i think this is a very enjoyable
series um it probably
it it probably is going to be some
people's favorites and it's probably
going to sit at the bottom for some
people i'm not going to rate it yet
because again this isn't a review uh i
will go into details tomorrow about you
know things i like things i didn't like
but my overall reaction was it's fun
it's it's really really fun and it's got
a lot of
important parts i think to it that fans
are going to enjoy and speculate on a
lot which of course you know i will be
doing here on the channel it's got a ton
of crazy good characters uh there are
some cameos that you all already know
about that are really really good it's
great to see these characters on screen
with each other um
final thing
they say you know it's an attorney at
law show don't go in expecting like law
and order because it's still a marvel
show and it still pretty much just
focuses on you know she-hulk's life
jennifer walters is life and uh it's fun
it's funny um the fourth wall breaking
is i thought very clever they use it
in very clever ways but sometimes i feel
like uh it's inconsistent
but there's so much potential there and
again it's just overall
fun
and i like it so far and i'm excited to
see where it goes um i'm really curious
to hear the fandoms opinion on this
again i think people are going to love
it i think people are going to hate it
some people might just
say like hey no it's fun i'm here for
the ride i'm going to watch it all and
uh enjoy the cool connections to the mcu
and enjoy learning about jennifer
walters and welcome a new she-hulk to
the mcu or welcome the she-hulk to the
mcu welcome a new hulk to the mcu and i
do think this character is going to be
around for a while and i am happy about
that because i think overall it's going
to be a really good character and a
really fun time having her in the mcu
let me know your initial thoughts on the
trailers that you all have seen so far
what you think the show is going to be
like if you think you're going to like
it or not and look out tomorrow for my
non-spoiler review where i'll go into a
little bit more detail so in the
meantime don't forget to like this video
and subscribe please if you're not
already subscribed to the channel you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter for live updates and as always
i'll catch you all next time woof